[Music]
okay everybody I am honored today to be
joined by the legendary actress slash
rock star Juliette Lewis who plays nedra
Frank in the new HBO limited series I
know this much is true
Juliette how are you doing in these
crazy times I'm doing good all things
considered in other times I might be
hanging on by a thread
but you know as well and my mom is
healthy so that makes me happy good
that's really good to hear so I think
there was just an exciting reaction
people had seen you in the show on
Sunday night I really wanted to delve
into that scene you had with Mark
Ruffalo at the end there when you show
up to Dominic's house and he says to you
about the manuscript so is it almost
done and you respond can you just not
pressure me I just do not do well with
pressure I feel when you said that line
I know that type of person so well okay
what I was wondering though for you this
character of nature did this come from a
person you knew her as part of Juliet in
nedra no I wanted to meet a person that
lying by the way it was Sookie that's so
instrumental to who that person is at
that point in her life she's a pressure
cooker
she's like a cyclone that were it comes
through Dominic's life and you know I
did my research talking to a couple
women who are in that world they're in a
man's game it's the late 80s they're the
world of academia you're getting you
know patronized everywhere you turn the
pressure is ever mounting they have
stacks of papers you know never
finishing you're barely making ends meet
so all of that was informative of where
she's at and then you match that with
all her neuroses or her competitiveness
with men her you
she basically dumps everything that
she's doing to Dominic meaning
objectifying accusing him of wanting one
thing that's her she's doing all that so
like all people she just wants to be
held no but it's really funny
to play this juggernaut of energies and
neuroses and also visually to look
different the curly hair I really wanted
her to a curly hair I should have wanted
her to be messy but she's she's wet you
know well really tight and then she's in
a very professional high brow in her
world arena so she dresses up her mess
with good speaking skills right so to
your point about saying that you know
she's got all this energy to her there's
a life to her she's like a firecracker
you've been in this game of acting your
whole life you're just an incredible
actress how do you keep though that
energy up how do you find the motivation
to keep giving a hundred and ten percent
which you always do in your roles but
especially here like where are you
finding that now late in the game
well yes it feels like my whole life but
I haven't done acting my whole life but
yes it was very young I gotta tell you
that's the quest the quest is always how
to meet each experience with a fresh
head and with vigor the vigor of youth
but what was radical about this
experience was Derek the filmmaker Derek
and Mark together as a team mark is one
of my favorite actors he's one of the
great
I'd never I know him personally but we
never worked together and Derek see in
France this director blew my mind the
way he approaches things he wants you to
discover things you that weren't written
so that's new that's different in the
land of TV when you're under the gun for
time you don't often go to a fat
go hey let's through a thousand takes
and we're gonna try different versions
you're gonna be more composed at the end
or you're gonna explode or you're gonna
try this so we really got to have fun in
the action of it it was really great
yeah that's interesting you say that I
noticed too there's like little
brilliance in your performance here
especially like when Dominic first hands
you the beer and you scowl at it looking
at it that it's rolling rock like I
wonder like how much of that is improv
on set so you're saying he's giving you
guys a lot of room to kind of breathe
and just oh yeah yeah most of it most of
it
you're just playing off each other you
know what is structured is she enters
the doorway see you know the starting
points you start to seem but we had to
find all of it
where I walk oh my god that was the
other thing Derek had the way the DP
works is they could follow you so
possess unusual - usually you you
structure your behavior and and so this
was very loose so that the majority of
it was all it was filmed and not too
much is premeditated but of course if
it's written in a scene they were a
pizza and then there's a time cut you go
get the pizza and and stuff like that
but yeah I can't wait to see it I
haven't seen it and and each you know
I'm in a few episodes but each thing is
so there's a whole journey to it from
where they start to where they end up
and and how nedra is helping Dominic
marks journey as characters journey of
discovering the mythology of his
grandfather and his family through he
needs nedra to translate this manuscript
so from what we saw in the first episode
would you say nedra at all actually
wants to genuinely help him with this
manuscript or she kind of holding this
over his head to like keep her in his
life yes he's the funny one because
tin roofs meaningless she sees this
macho man the first thing she sees you
know she literally is what she's
accusing a man of being is that he walks
into her space she is so stressed
overworked underslept
underpaid and and yes she's going to
translate the manuscript but also as a
woman she's just seeing this man and
he's like a hobby like a pet project how
is she gonna unwind
how was she unwind this guy and she does
it through all her weird reverse
psychology
but yes on the surface yes she needs to
get paid so she's gonna translate as a
manuscript and then he pisses her off so
what I want to know too is what you just
said about you know he pisses her off so
when she actually goes in to kiss him
and dance with him it towards the end
there she can you just explain a little
bit because like is she snapping at that
moment because he's apparently laughing
right like that's how I was kind of
reading it like does she feel completely
ejection there oh yeah this is such a
fun scene because we talked derek mark
and i we all talked about moments where
you've been on either side of that
experience where you're miss reading
signals do you think if someone's
feeling one way or the other and the
whole thing and then disaster and I
think it's so funny I just love I just
love uncomfortable moments in life and
then what you get to express those in a
story because we all go through it but
oh my god yeah this is really funny and
the rejection and we also know what
Dominic's feeling he's not feeling this
woman at all she's a disaster so the
whole thing his confliction is really
interesting as well yeah absolutely
um also by the way you
just steal this seem to with your drunk
dancing it's so OnPoint
it's so good it's so funny so but what I
always think is like I know you've been
open about being sober since your 20s
how do you tap into that now and it can
can it be uncomfortable for you in some
ways like doing that um oh I don't want
to give the wrong I'm not I'm not a so
like I'm not I'm just not an alpha like
I want me but I don't do drugs I'm not
like a so I just don't want to give the
wrong yes I drink a pina colada here and
there okay so your your actor is
drinking a beer in that scene you're not
drinking like apple juice
oh god you got you know no I just didn't
want to give the wrong thing I'm not I
since I was 22 I don't I don't do drugs
or stuff like that okay anyway so the
playing those scenes that is it's a
challenge it's really fun to play
there's a couple things in acting
they're fun to play and they could be
done really bad and that's acting buzz
or drunk people can do it really poorly
and so I'm glad to hear you say it
looked like a drunk girl trying to be
seductive because that's what I was and
Derek was so fun he's this let it roll I
was like oh my god this two months or
whatever because as Juliet me doing it
it's so uncomfortable because it's
seeing it's full of herself it's the
worst thing when drunk people think
they're composed or looking cool or
whatever and they're a train wreck so
that was really fun to do I can't wait
to see it actually what he used oh yeah
and he lets it go that's what I love
about his work he's like you were saying
that's the scene play out and I think
that just makes it have such a big
payoff I I wonder - you just said about
her being like you know this very like
kind of narcissistic person like do you
also feel she has some sort of like
martyr syndrome yeah yeah what she wants
to do I have no doubt that she's
experienced challenge
she's in a what was predominantly a mail
run profession and she's trying to find
her own voice and assert her own voice
within this world of being a scholar so
but I also think there are people that
set up situations where they can play
that out like see what you did to me you
did this so that's exactly we watch her
not being with it you know to me not
giving a [ __ ] about another person's
perspective and then accusing them of
not carrying my hearse it's great I love
that yeah it was so neat to play
personality like that who's a real
Blamey
yeah well here's what you're saying so
what she's also she's super intelligent
and I feel very confident at what she
does okay
I love that Juliet thank you so much for
joining me and talking about this
episode it was a lot of fun is there
anything else you would like to plug
besides I know this much is true at the
moment I guess what I want to say is
just this is exciting too I mean to be
to give people a story and something
they can have an adventure with and and
have some good entertainment and then
wait to plug oh I'm selling some
t-shirts on my Instagram that goes to
charity for animal rescue because the
animals always need help and saving on
so you can always go to my Instagram
that's just my name Juliette Lewis and
there's some cute things and it goes to
charity and I like doing yes that and
some great videos on that Instagram
account as well including that boss
[ __ ] challenge that just came out
please watch it if you haven't seen that
oh yeah
no eval great that we bail first rate
stunt coordinator who did Quinton's last
movie with Brad Pitt and DiCaprio I
worked with her on this roller derby
movie anyway it's just really a fun
viral video where we're all pretending
to be hit and giving punches and check
it out
love it you heard it from her yourself
check her out and I know this much is
true Sunday nights at 9:00 p.m. on HBO
and you can also get that HBO on demand
and HBO go and check out her music she
is an awesome musician as well she kicks
ass thank you so much Juliet for joining
me and I hope to talk to you soon
thank you so much and stay healthy and
safe they die